go I regret it I regret it I regret it I
regret it am I gonna wing this flew out
[Music]
snowpiercer a new show coming to TBS and
2020 it's all about the world's
remaining citizens living on a
perpetually moving trend in the show the
trains poorest citizens are only
rationed bug bars to eat so we wanted to
test our bug knowledge with a high
6-game of true or false
[Music]
hmm
true or false cockroaches aren't that
adaptable and cannot survive in most
environments I read on the internet that
cockroaches can survive like nuclear
blasts Metron correct
they are super adaptable that tries to
like trick me right there yeah they're
super we're supposed to be friends worms
are about 1000 times stronger than
people relative to their size I've never
seen a worm I've never seen a worm with
ABS yeah I'm fine yeah sure
true it's true don't worry there's a lot
of protein in that American cockroaches
can reach speeds up to 3 miles per hour
American cockroaches though do you know
something about yes true Oh 3 miles per
hour oh no did you get a piece of
something crickets were named for the
sounds they make Cheers
friendship you fair crunch mosquitoes
usually pee on you and they suck your
blood true and I'm into it
this is true oh wait
cockroaches can withstand a nuclear
explosion
sure sure that is a true thing this is
actually cockroaches can survive like
nuclear blasts oh I try not to chew
there is nothing in existence like rye
bread and then you like soaked it in
like sewage water I feel like with like
wood chips oh and then there's some
crunchy stuff in front you like
disgusting potato chips
[Music]